in the first week of april 2020
president donald trump in his daily
white house coronavirus briefings
talked about an anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine
as a treatment against covid19 quoting a
questionable french study
he said that we don't have time to go
and take a couple of years to test it
out
he also added that the us has amassed 29
million doses
of this drug meanwhile dr anthony foshi
the country's top infectious disease
doctor has repeatedly warned that there
is no conclusive evidence to support
using this drug
the story of how hydroxychloroquine
became a wonder drug
for the corona virus pandemic is a
modern tale of misinformation due to
widespread uncertainty
fear and media fragmentation hello and
welcome to math simplified
today we'll be talking about the demand
miracle drug of the r
hydroxychloroquine what is it how does
it work
does it really help against covad19 and
the most important question
should you take it hydroxychloroquine is
a medication
used to prevent and treat malaria across
the globe especially in the southeast
asia regions
and the south american regions other
uses of hydroxychloroquine
include treatment of rheumatoid
arthritis lupus
and porphyria cutanea tarda it is one of
the possible treatments that scientists
in china and south korea looked at it
at the early stage of the coronavirus
outbreak experiments
were promising but conclusive results
were not available
the drug was also selected by the world
health organization
and it included it in its large-scale
international clinical trial
however we are not including covid19 in
this list
because currently there is no conclusive
evidence to support using the drug for
covert 19 patients
in early march as the coronavirus
pandemic accelerated its spread around
the globe
a group of scientists in martial france
launched an experiment to see whether
hydroxychloroquine
a well-known old malaria drug could be
that what everyone was searching for
a cure for corona before the study was
even published
in the international journal of
antimicrobial agents igaa
a lawyer falsely claiming an affiliation
with stanford university
appeared on prime time news in usa and
declared the results
he falsely claimed that
hydroxychloroquine has 100
cure rate against coronavirus
this false news spread like wildfire
scientists called out the false claims
but
it was too late across the globe and
throughout diverse communities on the
internet
hydroxychloroquine was anointed the
miracle cure for kovace 19.
if you have followed our previous two
videos on vaccines you may remember the
term clinical trials
the goal of a clinical trial is to
determine two things
whether the drug works or not and
it is safe or not
to prevent any kind of falls and
inaccurate results clinical trials have
a set of rules
that need to be followed by the
researchers neither the physician
nor the patient knows whether they are
receiving the drug or not
this is known as double blinding the
researchers also do not get to choose
which patients go into which group
and this is known as randomization the
makeup of the two groups
is roughly equivalent that is why it is
known as a controlled study
the french hydroxychloroquine study did
not follow
any of these rules the study was flawed
and the results were inaccurate and
meaningless
initially they selected 42 patients and
out of them two left the study and four
had bad outcomes
the other 36 eventually recovered and
those who received the drug
cleared the virus from the system faster
than those who did not
six were excluded from the top line
results and they were left out of the
final analysis
based on just 36 patients who completed
the study
those who received the drug cleared the
virus from their system faster than
those who did not
this is how there was a false 100 cure
rate
in fact on april 3 two weeks after the
study was published
the international society of
antimicrobial chemotherapy
said in a statement that the group's
board believes
the article does not meet society's
expected standard
especially relating to the lack of
better explanation of the inclusion
criteria and the triage of patients to
ensure
patient safety this raises huge
questions about the validity of the
results and whether or not they should
be followed
meanwhile scientists and physicians
continue to study the effect of the drug
another group of french researchers
published a document on 30th march
the researchers at st louis hospital in
france
followed the same regime of
hydroxychloroquine for 11 patients
and they did not find any results which
were similar to those
seen in the previous controversial study
topics we found no evidence of a strong
antiviral activity
or clinical benefit of
hydroxychloroquine and azithromycin
for the treatment of our hospitalized
patients with severe covate 19
they wrote but another study this time a
randomized control trial out of wuhan
china
has sparked a trial containing 62
patients with
mild cases of covid19 was done
researchers found out that the patients
who were treated with hydroxychloroquine
recovered faster than those who did not
and none of them progressed to severe
illness
now the burning question of the are
should you take hydroxychloroquine for
covid19
well at med simplified we believe that
any medication taken without guidance of
a trained medical professional
can have grave consequences like in case
of hydroxychloroquine the drug is known
to cause
various side effects such as heart
rhythm problems severe low blood
pressure
and muscle or nerve damage sadly few
cases of overdoses have also been
reported in u.s and nigeria
as some frightened individuals attempted
to self-medicate
do not take hydroxychloroquine unless
advised by a healthy professional under
supervision
let the decision of whether
hydroxychloroquine is to be used or not
to be taken by the medical professional
after thorough research and a fair
conclusive trial
so this was all about hydroxychloroquine
if you want to support med simplified
you can do it by supporting it on
patreon.com for literally the price of a
coffee cup
check all the links below in the
description bar this helps us hire more
people for our team
and make better videos for you guys only
thank you so much for watching